ladies and gentlemen it's Wednesday we
got the great Bert Kreischer who we
wanted to get on the podcast a long time
13 yep and and we call them the bird
I've never heard any to call the machine
on machines never heard one bad thing
about you in everybody seems to like you
you're a big jolly funny man with a
beard and by the way Pierce both his
ears oh yeah I did that with my daughter
as well my daughters and I didn't want
someone to go last and so they wanted to
get their ears pierced we were in London
yeah and there were daddy you just gave
you go last I'm like imma get my ears
pierced and like just go laughs and so I
went to last yeah and I enough I was
telling them to be brave and I moved and
they miss Pierce them and so they're not
in like the perfect space it to be so I
put what you've got you got tasteful
diamond studs in your ears this is all
right well by her bed and the head and
they over piercings I moved so it went
past the part we're supposed to stop so
it was tight
so like the for London we're having
dinner at a castle and my ears are red
my wife's like they don't look at her
and they don't look then I was like
remember when we were kids we got our
ears pierced and we were like not
[ __ ] cleaning them like just get me
over you never do it I never clean them
they got infected really bad damn yeah
have young person no I never have
pierced ears know you're here ahead uh
forty years can be never sir do I look
like a little boy with no so wait hold
on wait you're my age you definitely
went through that period what was like
spring break like everyone yeah
everyone's peers in the ears get a
feather and considered it I considered
it subversive and even communist like
and I was like I'm an American and I got
a [ __ ] fight for my god forbid the
Soviets invaded I with pierced ears I
want them to see that I was a man I know
we had a lot of weird [ __ ] going on in
my head I don't see how I'm doing this
ooh ah might be ugly I'd rather do it at
the time we're like I think mm had it
like all the white rappers do it yeah
heard my brother did and he had Lily for
an hour I came home and he's like what's
up Mike she impaired sports tears and
just not draw any attention like what's
wrong that way you cannot terrible
actress right out there only time is
gonna be awful
have you had your
you ever been had your hair cut and had
your ear cut yeah you're having my mom
my momma taught my eye off what do you
say stay pro2 Polly my [ __ ] is oh oh
no yeah I've got a scar on the top of
one of my ears it's on one of them from
my mom cutting my ear the top off and I
was like oh yeah Saigon I'm sorry I was
thinking of something else I wish I
would did that my after my first year of
MADtv I'm in New York City and I got
recognized by maybe three people it was
such a thrill to me like I by the way to
this day when I get recognized
I still it doesn't get old I still will
give the person way too much time like
I'm the guy who actually tires the fan
out so Oscar he knows he'd see my GoPro
will you act like you've been here
before my thanks and I keep them there
I'm the war I mean I will give them all
the time they while talking about their
family so this this woman I'm what 27
and I walk into it to get my haircut and
a woman who's kind of young and kind of
attractive she goes oh my god oh my god
I watched you we watch you all the time
my family and I love you I'm pool boy or
whatever and I'm like holy [ __ ] in the
whole place is looking over I feel like
a celebrity I'm like this is amazing
peer so I go give me a haircut long
story short she first of all butchers my
hair she cut to super shrugs eyes and
leaves the table long I look like a
mushroom I look like a mushroom I look
like a skinny mushroom head I look like
a [ __ ] head like you know when they boof
your hair all up how many ten look I'm
already that I have already said that
I'm long and skinny and my neck is too
long anyway so I'm like now I got like
if you want to bring me down give me a
regular guide b-57 if my neck wasn't all
my height is in my neck and my torso on
my [ __ ] hair now then she cuts my ear
so badly I'm so badly and I'm Bob but
I'm like so gracious because I'm built
up with it I do it I went oh oh like
that I made a weird noise like I like
that I think it's just oh I'm sorry I'm
5 in 5
it's lovely so badly that it's coming
down my cheek my mom lies just to pay
for it dude
I of course because I was like it's fun
and I kept going it's totally fine I
didn't feel it I was bleeding so bad he
was so [ __ ] being my
wanted me to go get a tetanus shot I'm
like I'm not getting a tetanus shot
what are you talking if your cut man has
grown men what'd he get here wait wait
wait wait I had the worst haircut
experience ever
I go my wife what we were dating for
months and she dumped me she was like oh
yes she said I think you have a drinking
problem
anything on porn fair pointer paranoid
me lady
married that woman with a 14-year a
parting article a wake-up call little
party party [ __ ] it's a wait okay so I
had my head I get my barber I won't say
his name he's a hair stylist used to do
Dave Navarro Ozzy Osbourne here's the to
the star em it was hardly a deployment
in the appointment he lived in like San
Francisco knee fly down once a month
damn
- this guy was great I would hit this
whole place but he would come in and his
haircuts were expensive and were they
what they cost like 120 bucks
I wanna [ __ ] were you doing that because
because I was on TV at the time and so
and so I met this guy Knight trusted the
way come ere went through a 12-step
program with Dave Navarro like like he's
the partier I used to really party yeah
Harvey he had to say the least
like Robin he's got a nice body I used
to see him change of crunch you take a
shirt off with his pierced nipple he's
got a beautiful did you ever see him
work out in the hyperbaric chamber that
was off to the left no but he would kick
the bag and do karate and he talked
about his master he was bobbing up buddy
got the dick on him - I've seen him in
the steam room - and I could not stop
staring at it
oh it was because if you have twos all
around it is wrong you in we've got a
dick oh you got a regatta [ __ ] you
know he keeps that [ __ ] Bush well
manicured I wouldn't be surprised if
he's got not a stitch a hair there went
baby my life baby I hear he's great as
eyeliner deliverer
yeah um so so I go in I realized the day
after I've been dumped that I have a
haircut and I call up and I go I'm gonna
have to push it no like he's not coming
back for like another month and a half
so I wouldn't push it so I go [ __ ] it
I'll go in this is how cools got these
have a pool table in there I walk in it
gives me a big hug he goes man you're
looking down and I go my chick dumped me
because she says I drink too much he
goes man this is my expertise I mean I'm
really dialed in for this
he was come back we go back to the bar
and he cracks two beers right and he
goes hey man I started partying again I
go really any goes yeah so I know what
you're going through you say how many
people told you of a drinking problem I
go her and her best friend that's it
here's that's it I oh yeah he goes die
you sure I said yeah he goes okay here's
my rule if one person tells you how to
tail
[ __ ] them the crazy if two people tell
you have a tail they're teaming up on
you but if three people tell you have a
tail that's when you need to turn around
is a great experience I've ever heard
and then he says you wanna smoke some
weed
alright so yeah you can't let anyone in
here know that I'm partying like this
they know that I had a beer the other
night let's go to the bathroom so this
was the worst guy to talk to when you're
like when you're trying to really light
me over I know what an enabler we go
into the bathroom we get high he comes
out he's like man nothing she won't like
a great haircut and I'm looking you up
man and he pulls out a razor blade and
starts cutting my hair with a thumb
eraser [ __ ] Wyatt give me a bullet
and cut my bangs you're like you
remember Tropic Thunder
yeah God will return back we're both
high astronomer good it doesn't look at
this terrible crash two more beers
oh oh [ __ ] so perfect simple Jack you
look like simple Jack yeah I ain't got a
haircut things like I got another guy
coming over I'm gonna go meet him back
at the bar I'll see you know my dad
knows like I'll never go to you again
ever
thanks for the advice man no bad I went
back by the way you got a tail see you
later yeah I had a mullet like you left
this at the end hair long and he cut my
bangs back to the very top and it was
like goofy up top but also my Roku
because who's [ __ ] and I thought man
it'll look the way I'm like dude you're
a bad [ __ ] when you deal with a
razor though and a thumb a razor a thumb
is highest or you get high you're high
as [ __ ] yeah you don't think I want to
try something on this guy and just and I
don't have hair that you
can do that within the first place like
I'm holding on to my hair always we have
dinner at the Dave Navarro or [ __ ]
Ozzy Osbourne probably not know but he
used to go to Ozzy Osbourne's house and
diets and diazien's morons hair like he
had he was go to their houses and cut
their hair he was the he was a great guy
I really enjoyed them but that one hair
at the last here's the last time I ever
saw him well kind of legit like stylist
oh yeah I mean I didn't do it sounds
funny yet like the find Sony actually
got here is Abby's look into dishes this
guy at least got my wife's hair and
charge of fortune but he was good he's
like really good yeah and he goes he I
saw him on set I was shooting a TV show
came over the show but anyway maybe it
was high mention my camera so uh he he
said to my wife he said happier rocks I
came to figure out and he looked at my
hair and he said he said happier uh
under his breath to a keynesian you
should have your husband come and talk
to me he's not being taken care of and
my life's like go see him I go man I'm
Gary shave you know I'm nothing's gonna
do so I see him and he's so great he's a
go what would you do to my hair and he
took Vegas magic sold all right so these
are magically reflected magic and I was
like I'm in yeah it would have cost me
twenty bucks never won I never did it no
but I know worried imagine I've kidding
I just don't see I'm sorry does not look
it look at me you're honest with me what
are you really gonna do with my hair
and by the way if you do magic how long
is it gonna last for me you know I just
can't
I'm not high maintenance like you don't
I mean do you seem to be [ __ ] grown
hair like a sprout you're not living in
here I've got a row game for 25 years
you don't take propecia bro as I know I
already said it [ __ ] up his dick I'll
[ __ ] that books I always say game
depression - I've been taking it forever
it's [ __ ] great to take propecia yeah
dude I got I got to show you my dick
later I have no problem you give up you
can still I'm 15 I can [ __ ] I can [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I'll guess illusion and then
I'll [ __ ] again you know I can vouch for
that
I have sick a like I want to say you
were in the room but yeah I told you are
saying I just heard say yes I have seen
is big
wrong yeah yeah i dick jad you've had
that thing in your math what but you're
not but you're but you're not losing me
like if you have more face on your beard
yeah it's I could I could you rub it on
your face no no no no everyone else says
it looks like I dye my beer because I
might beard when it's longer you can't
see the idea enough gray when it's short
you can see gray I mean yeah you're
hairy do I do i do I dye my beer not not
now certain times you're lazy with it
yeah do you really know I haven't dyed
it but I'm going to but for men losing
like the top your hair's like the that's
probably the biggest kind of fear if you
have you have your hair makes me angry
Oh your hair makes me angry I thought
about your hair today because I call my
guy Romi my best guy go to now and I
said I'm gonna get a haircut before
Hawaii and then I and then I was like I
go I want to do something different and
I thought I want to do what Brenda does
like you know real tight man hair and
you and I will never look like him at
all he's a different human being look at
him never a six-foot four I was looking
at his shoulders and it's because I was
looking at this [ __ ] girl
these girls were looking at him they
were looking at his shoulders and he's
you know we were standing in line he's
just so much taller and he's got those
ridiculously broad shoulders that V out
and I was like what a dick like I love
him he's like my brother but I'm like
this is ridiculous
work out here what's up and I'm like I'm
like I like abuse I ran five miles today
in Danville under fifty minutes good for
you but had you seen that online
you would've been like that was a work
okay guys we use Beauty slow down to a
six to take a sip of coffee like Willy
[ __ ] what's wrong with you he's a pro
athlete I don't know if me too because I
was boxing and I said what did you like
when did you start actually be on slip
punches in these double-helix maybe
about six months I won Golden Gloves
what he won't warm for me I go I'm
having trouble because I'm not he goes
hey hey
hold on I'm pro athlete you want to do
this right now he's gonna kill me
otherwise I'm fine I'm fine wait what
especially saving well I would trade all
that every guy's creativity Bert helped
me I went to Berkeley I didn't tell
anyone you know but the I need help with
that that doing that show um this is not
happening yeah yeah it's not a story and
Bert's like yeah we at the Comedy Store
in Brookes like I help you I go to this
house
and just burped was like oh let's just
record it you never know what kind of
help you even get you know how it is you
never know and bertigo was just
recording this thing and I told my story
goes dude this is I love your stories
being positively just that I'm a repeat
your story backing this wife ink it and
dude I was like I walked like oh my girl
Mike Bert's [ __ ] amazing like it's
your call like you know and like it was
some of the you know Brian Houston all
the time it was like the best [ __ ]
you know I was one to tell you this it
was like xunit respond but it was like
what did respond I have ever I responded
him you didn't respond that hurt my
feelings but I was just like dude not a
lot of people and a lot of people helped
me and that help was like I mean it
helped so [ __ ] him or else professional
like imagine we record it and I keep
going over and over and just it's helped
me so much so I thought about that story
probably an unhealthy amount because it
is really one of my favorite stories
I've heard in a long time I love a good
story I'm you know I veered away I
started I I was talking to hotel about
this yesterday um I wanted to be I
didn't know my voice for a long time and
I was naturally a storyteller but I
never felt like I never liked the guys
that I saw doing story I kind of kind of
they did too much of one thing it wasn't
like there was no naturalness to it and
then Rogen's one that changed my career
I told the Machine story on his podcast
and he said you need to tell that every
time you're on stage until it's good and
I was like no it's not a stage story he
Rogen's like no that's what a good comic
does good comic works on the [ __ ]
material because it's folding steel yeah
yeah he goes he yeah he's like you it's
the best story I've ever heard
and then he said to the fans of the
podcast this is right when his pocket
started lifting off he was like you guys
chant out the machine and Tilly tells
him on stage and that taught me so much
about story and about what I like about
it and what I like what I enjoy about it
but your story I literally I I'm not
called segura I go do this is one of my
favorite stories I've ever heard because
it's here it's a hero's journey it's it
is it's everything you love in wanting
to see an arc and then failure but
rising again out of the ashes so I've
talked about it a lot I was insecure
about destroyer I don't like the same
thing you know how your tell
bro you like it I don't think it belongs
on stage I don't feel like this belongs
on stage I feel like you're [ __ ] I feel
like people and go oh here we go
child with this [ __ ] hero still no
know people I love it yeah people want
to hear also the ins and outs of what
you've been through because it's still
very very strange to us so those of us
have not fought those who has not been
behind the scenes at the UFC does not
walk that gauntlet doesn't not have to
say somebody across from us those of us
that haven't lost haven't had a [ __ ]
giant knock us uh you know unconscious
or semi-conscious in the face with their
fists and all that humiliation all that
fear all that the taste of victory
that [ __ ] is like what I always tell you
that stuff that people have never gone
through we don't understand what that's
like what everybody goes through their
own thing but it's very interesting it's
very rigid and try to man away from that
but when birt did it kind of gave me
like all this new hope and I was I still
laughed some of the parts but I was
[ __ ] cracking up man I was done it
was great I called Ari right after
immediately and was like I go it's my
favorite story I've heard in a long time
I said all it needs all it needs all the
only thing and this is what I did with
my obsessive compulsiveness is I just
chew on the ending I keep chewing on the
ending cuz it's Bryan Callen and I want
and it's through another another word
but I can't find it up googled online
and if that you can paint that the right
way it can be fantastic but the biggest
difference is it's just like Brian said
about dodging a punch I was just I was
good at six months in comedy were like
whitey pretty good at this but I also
have been doing it every weekend six
times a weekend like for 18 years so all
year so I just it's like but even still
like I have stories now that I go like
sit with the TEL yesterday I was like
David tells like a savant right I've
never had him everyone tells me how did
I missed that boat I'm I've heard even
someone I've never seen firsthand his
work but everyone I know says how big a
deal is on something last night I was
talking to him and he was we're just
hanging out I hadn't seen him and like
he'll say stuff like this I go I'm I go
I don't really like Hollywood that much
me sitting and smoking and Dave's
probably never done a push-up or even a
vegetable he's just sitting there
smoking he's out there with exactly is
too big for him
Rome and I go I don't like Hollywood you
know I just it's just just a mercenary
town I like the West Side it was plus
there are no good Dodos here right you
do need good dough doing would you like
that by the way he did a two-man thing
with Jeff Ross yesterday where they were
talking back and forth we were [ __ ]
dying will you say Bella guy Burt oh god
I don't know about you always spoke I of
all so I will say to her all your
listeners who are in your boat right now
that don't know Attell right now by
skanks for the memories it is the most
it is the perfect representation of what
stand-up comedy should be it is it has
no fat on it everything that said it has
a purpose and everything this has has a
tag and a joke that he's thought over
three or four times I played it for my
daughter in the car today and there's a
part where he talks about if I was a
[ __ ] I'd be late everywhere I go I go
oh he goes I tell where we're trying to
run a Chocolate Factory here where are
you where were you he goes look at these
are the legs there was a puddle I had to
swim it and my daughter was doubled over
laughing dude he's amazing and he's
you're right and and scheduling I mean
what if skanks for the everything some
they love just mister but why hasn't he
worth more why isn't he on the same
level as like a Jim Carrey or you know
because he wasn't he was an actor and
and and he was more of a guy who would
he go to in one place and would kill you
with with his jokes oh he's a great
writer but it's a great writer great
comedian right like there's certain guys
like named some guys you know like
there's certain guys who just killed as
straight up comedians right you haven't
but I think the ones that I'm always
drawn to and I'm by the way I think I'm
definitely in Brian's camp I don't know
how you do it I really don't know how
you do it because you actually have a
blossoming career in acting that's been
going on for your entire career and
you've been doing killing it and
stand-up and in podcasting I was on when
I did Travel Channel it sucked the
stand-up atomy because you were all in
production mode tell Tom Segura and Bill
burr Jim Jefferies I'll throw him in
that camp they just focused on stand-up
a burr and Segura and a tell all they
care about is doing another special
right in the material Jim Norton still
the same way Jim dabbles in everything
else but like they're just focused on
stand-up Tom scre has never been on
television if you have any desire to
know why he's selling out multiple shows
on theatres a night and then go to the
next city and doing multiple shows
interference I by the way I've known him
probably 15 years and to watch that
growth is so astounding and to go
Netflix like no television no like I'll
go I've ever had he had that one
algorithm he did that Netflix thing and
it was put in a place where people
watching it I think off a burr yeah but
then they realize have funny Thomas icon
the [ __ ] Thomas talking guys you're
welcome and I always say you I was
talking to Justin it Justin's not your
guy right now
I love the Sun just another night way of
toy store and I thought about doing Tom
as a top 10 in the top like this there's
10 guys that are just [ __ ] monsters
right now you in Tom Marin that Lieber
Berhad me laughing as hard as I laughed
with as hard as I laughs to tell he's
number one to me burst number one he I'm
like a give away his material his new
material what a hero is
I was it's hard to make me laugh but you
know I see I'm the rent cut so hard make
me laugh it was just like new stuff
yours on the community I was in the
crowd and I was [ __ ] howling I could
not get enough of it this is so
brilliant I was there this it's kind
blowing it me and Neal Brennan were
watching over just like Neal brand
another one I got to be able to be a
third mic is one of the is one of my
favorite specials I've seen how original
is that three my its original original I
would say this to Neal I would have just
I would have just weaved it all to one
mic I mean I like the branding of the
three mics I like I like I liked that he
was going to set up punches and I
understand the struggle of being a set
up punch guy along with a story guy
along with a vulnerable guy but that's
one of the things I like about Neal is
that is that he is a multi-faceted guy
who also directs commercials makes
movies rights for people goes and just
sits on my wife's coin three times I got
a [ __ ] answer it
are you okay okay yeah yeah I'm doing a
podcast tell them I'm sorry I'm tell
them I'm sorry okay okay tell them tell
them I'm um
I'm coming okay I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm
in I'm in Venice right now also I do
yeah I'm but I'm in the middle of a
really great podcast Russia
tell them I'm really sorry oh wait no
but Jenna tell them you're on your way
I mean yeah sure yeah yeah yeah no I
understand I get all of that but I'm not
there and I'm at a podcast I'm sorry
yeah I'm really sorry I'm please tell
them that I'm I'm gonna finish up in a
little while and I'll be there like 2x I
there's nothing I can do
oh oh she hung up on ya like I love him
know who is there who's a rat it's dying
laughing it's uh earthed it's uh I don't
know it's TV show yeah I love this she's
well I'll be there like what we were
looking say yes you have a teleport
[ __ ] miss you I don't know what this
yeah but what am I supposed to say to
them I'm not there you can tell him that
yeah but so say literally just say not
he's out here he's in the closet you'd
let me know let me go talk to him
hydrated there and then just wait yeah
but what the [ __ ] angry yeah were you in
your lives in Hollywood up no let's um
I've kind of written them off because
there's no way I'm gonna make it to them
while they're there no way no way when
you said I leave I went in traffic it's
three Clair's I'm you guys hours of left
I didn't I didn't realize that we pushed
this hill to and so I just I really had
no news I was never going to make that
shoot I didn't just didn't look at my
calendar you texted me and I was like
this is definitely more important than
that no I mean no offense dying laughing
that is our that's the kind of [ __ ] I
would do yeah and that's a guy [ __ ] I do
do well that's how I'm horrible dies
there there hello I'm gonna heroin
addict like and give them me the leeway
they give every entertainer yeah
let me make a me see guys like they're
I'm not coming really cloud over there
in 15 minutes like what the [ __ ] I've
seen Chappelle just not show up like but
and then everyone's like he's a genius
how come I can't how come again mediocre
white action I gotta be there on time
[ __ ] but we're not before that
oh just segura and all that
yes captain but with yeah but you said
that I think Louie CK said this to row
you know if I'm not saying I shouldn't
but I've made me say on the podcast said
the complex is the common Stromer but
Louie CK said I really think to compete
these days and comedy and be like the
one of the top guys you can only do
stand-up probably the most oh you have
to focus on it so you know just that
because you never argue well I don't
yeah I mean I don't know I don't know if
I agree with that but look I at the same
time those guys you're right that they
focus solely on stand up and they're
killing it yeah so the argument would be
but then bill burr has his animated
series right he's not excited to he's
he's Lucy case we make a mistake every
comic that we all know everybody wants
their own TV show Jim Gaffigan did
everybody I know is always working and
for that self yeah you know I'm stuff
for Tom Segura comedy got meta a TV show
I'm always trying to develop stuff I
think the budget but yeah but it's kind
of podcast but well yeah I see but
that's a little different but I think I
think entertainment and being a creative
being an artist I mean that goes in with
TV movies stand up you know it's all one
big expression and I think the main
thing is just to be original and I also
think that you can always be writing and
coming up with great stuff I think I
think you know you you've got to just
kind of realize it it's just about
inspiration it's always work if you're
driving you should be writing yeah I see
but also if you're like let's say you're
Dave Chappelle doing the Chappelle show
the chance you come out with a solid
hour wall while Thompson girls solely
riding coming up with an hour
nice girls compete well you're here now
if you have spaces and your biggest
things to be trying to switch into that
mode right yeah if you're doing a TV
show like that especially a sketch show
man when you're doing sketch show it's
all-consuming and it's even like when I
was when I was doing a Travel Channel I
would be in really amazing scenarios and
I would not have my stand-up brain on
because you're just like I just wanna I
want to make sure we get out on time I
know the Sun sets at 6:00 yeah like and
you just want to work doing it and then
but then when you're a comic your brain
net like when you're just doing comedy
you can be at a funeral and just go and
buy them what's the what's the
what's the angle I'm experiencing
something now that everyone's gonna
experience at one point what's my bit
like you are you still working for
Travel Channel
no no stopped uh right like probably in
September and um and it was Chris Brogan
and Byrd shot me down on the Comedy
Store and they were like hey man burr
was the one that said it first he's like
you're too good of a comment to be
wasting your talent and Rogen's like you
know it really you need to be doing it
bird like you're not doing it and and
I'm like yeah but I'm here every now and
then I do the road every now and then
he's like that's not doing it you need
to be here every night you can kind of
well no foot out yeah and then they and
then it were the one thing because the
road they're both extremely wealthy men
they were like how much money do you
need to get by a year and I was like I
told them and they're like yeah you can
do it I'll stand up and I was like I
don't know and they're like you can do
it on stand-up if you focus on stand-up
and then with your podcast do you
monetize it then that'll be probably
more than you can make on Travel Channel
I was like no [ __ ] way
all right dude I'm making more of my
podcast right now then I was making on
Travel Channel yep considering I mean
obviously considering a Donuts pay
managers and agents
it just goes to my one podcasting agent
in me you can only hit burn yeah and I
was like and I am the second I quit my
numbers jumped exponentially like to the
point right like now I look at big
numbers and I go I thought it'd be
higher you know like like here it really
has competitive like the podcast more
especially now like even when the mom
has a podcast so the filters through all
that man you it you better look at like
a job like you somebody well I'll put
one up today I may be out doing this
doing that you can't you can't compete
people fighting the kid yeah I've never
missed Parkinson's for years adver you
need people with us well you know you
guys were the ones that I think that
agents were like wait this is a real job
you could do this as a real job CA has a
whole new branch for podcasts I
explained to my agent when they were
trying to get me to take jobs out of
town and explain to them look what what
this was what I was doing on this not
only monetarily but also just kind of
like the numbers and I said so what is
your what is with that whole show you're
talking about again do you want me to do
yeah what was that show that you wanted
me to do on TNT that nobody's gonna
watch what are you talking about well
how does that make any sense they're
like
holy they I guess didn't know is that
knowing it doesn't translate I
ultimately want to sell tickets at
weekends I want people to come out see
me do a lot of stand-up that's what I do
the best yeah and it doesn't translate
no one was finding me on travel channel
then going that guy screams really loud
on a rollercoaster let's go see it at
live David and they were just like now I
got news for you brother you can do a
major sitcom on CBS that that eight
million people watch a week in a time
the more it won't translate like a
podcast no podcast how long's podcast
hour and a half hour and a half usually
yeah I've heard a bunch done so I don't
have to our God I always say they're
good if they're over an hour and a half
correct so hour and a half so on is
dedicated listen to Bert Kreischer talk
for an hour and a half you don't think
of me sold on the human being you are
yeah when you come to their town like
there's no better way to sell tickets
yeah they find out you you're not
playing a character you're [ __ ] bird
that is what I talked about in therapy
today is that I I never enjoyed comics
who played a character who are doing an
act in the sense man I'm like I'm not
gonna say I can't relate to it like I'm
the like we'll just use Bob text I think
he's changed out of that but when I
found out that Bob cat didn't really
suffer my heart was broken the tab day
yeah and so like and but a bobcat not
stuttering and being Bobcat is [ __ ]
brilliant yeah and now that he's doing
that I love watching him do stand-up
right I can't imagine him doing the
character so I cut I blurred the line
very and I think podcasting did this I
blurred the line from what we've had in
therapy the Machine Burt this party guy
that I am I really am that guy and then
who I am in real life it is the same
person and I and it's like and then a
certain point you start going like like
like I'm with Stanhope this weekend and
I'm like yeah I'm I'm definitely the
Machine like we're drinking champagne at
6:00 in the morning getting ready to go
to find a pool to swim in who you are
yeah and I go I love it I love it but I
was like it could end up really killing
me like I need to learn how to dot find
Burt whoever I wasn't I'd animal and
just bring him into my into his life a
little bit to go hey buddy
so like that's why I'm out yeah hey man
remember remember how much fun it was my
baseball like let's go talk today yeah
you know just just
talks like about like what you're going
through yes one of the things that has
was sort of an unforeseen ramifications
doing his podcast because I need started
it I was like let's do a podcast so I
can sell tickets on the road that and
then all of a sudden you realize that
you start developing a fanbase that
really appreciates what you do like I
got an email I think was on Instagram a
guy who was in Manchester and you know
he has a daughter who's who likes Nicki
Minaj I'm sorry ariana grande and he was
he was like dude he goes and and I know
the people from that area and I you know
I know people know the people some of
the girl killer Chester's like New York
and he was saying yeah and he was saying
he was crying you know he's just crying
he had a kid and it's all this stuff and
he goes I put your [ __ ] podcast on
dude I forgot everything all I did was
laugh but we hear the [ __ ] all the time
bro we hear all the time like you guys
inspired me you guys you know make me
because you talk about you're so honest
all of a sudden you start to realize I
got a kind of a responsibility not to be
too often about it but I can't go
anywhere like it's on its own life like
it's kind of a responsibility the fat
shaming that segura and I did was
probably the biggest thing I've ever
done in my career and we did not it was
no I don't think either of us had an
intention for it to help our careers at
a point I think we thought we were
[ __ ] our careers up yeah but we
started fat shaming because you don't
know
Berta's fat thomas fat and then there's
everywhere and then and then we did we
started losing weight I lost 45 pounds
Wow and then we went on Rogan we did two
days back-to-back and it was uh I mean
there's so many people to Constantine
they're like hey man I lost 70 pounds so
far like I look at it I do it how did
you guys do it I I didn't really how
many I didn't do a very healthy harissa
girl if I was a bees of maniac yeah I
went like I have we call it the Mickey
Mantle gene just that Guy'd guy who can
go out and party and then get the [ __ ]
up very punitive and go I am not
allowing myself to get into a bad mood
about this we call that - John Jones
gene detective John Jones gene you can
party you can just you can kill it and
you're up and you're fine I'm up drop
off is seven
take the girls to school get back today
ramp five miles at the time I was doing
nine miles a day
jogging walking impressive very very
hardcore going to CrossFit non-stop and
eating under probably under 1200
calories but under a thousand some days
ah yeah and then um and all I drank was
Peters and soda and so and then I just
would be like I get done the club I'd if
I was doing a weekend I got done from
the club for two doses so to get on the
treadmill and just walk six miles at
like midnight while you're drinking
vodka I was drinking I used to drink
wine on the treadmill but Edna has wine
splashes all over yeah cause it makes it
faster distillate I used to turn on
diners drive-ins and dives
I turn on anything you one of these guys
that can drink like I can't drink right
so I can I can have one shot of tequila
on FOX right or two you can you show so
can you dink any kind of alcohol and and
in large quantities and kill it I mean
yeah yeah yeah
then my thing is you can't tell that I'm
drunk like no one can tell I'm drunk Wow
and so like so like yeah like this past
weekend we flew in through Thursday on a
private jet into Vegas to do the
crapshoot comedy festival I woke up
knowing I was going to party and I ran
five miles like first thing in the
morning got to the airport by like 10:00
in the morning
drank on the flight no show Thursday
drank there woke up with no hours sleep
came in they gave me an IV and a b12
shot so like a million bucks well like a
million bucks started drinking it radio
did two shows didn't sleep had an
hour-and-a-half sleep got on another
plane flew into Bisbee no sleep did a
show with Stanhope and Bizzy savage fell
asleep for like four hours and then woke
up started drinking with Stan hoping in
part like it was just it was really out
of control this weekend so when I got
home yesterday I by the way I got up ran
five miles did a podcast with a Talon
segura and then did a podcast Lewis J
Gomez went to sleep immediately because
I'm like oh yeah I'm wrecked but then
got up this morning I felt like [ __ ] I
hate housing I'm a schedule me to no
food I'm a little connection I'm
sensitive
I just don't what you don't my fate I
don't enjoy that you know like I would
enjoy the hustle and doing all that it
feels really good like to drink I think
my wife is like you my wife is way more
sturdy and in fact resents me that I
like I was taking a nap today and
she-she I could feel her her yeah I
could feel she walked in cuz I was
supposed to be helping her in the garage
and I got I hit a wall and I was like be
right back and I was pretending to go
like I was gonna go fast I just let her
[ __ ] and keep working the garage and I
went and passed out I would pass out she
I feel her goken she goes thank God yeah
well you're from you went to Florida
State yeah kind of requirement to be a
partying yeah it's been like that
Gainesville can tell I like Florida is
in game ok this it was funny the way I
remember there's a comedian Jordan Rubin
you know George yeah sure funny guy
Jordan I go to I moved to New York and
we're all at a loft and so Howard Jordan
lived in a loft a bunch other guys
really cool I bring three girls from
Florida State they're all models now in
New York and I'm doing stand-up I kind
of know Jordan and I and uh we had coke
and and I was like and I said Jordan I
get me half drunk and I go hey do you
mind if we go to your room to get high
and he's like no of course and so I walk
in with three girls Jordan walks he sees
me with beautiful girls he walks in
behind us and immediately I take his
mirror off the wall and put it down and
he bucket by the way I thought everyone
partied like this and he was like are
you guys doing coke and I was like
because when you say hi but I was like I
would never go into your room to smoke
marijuana like how long rude let's go
and get it all in your sheets like yeah
yeah how do you party like a handle
handle yeah yeah
God live Jordans like I didn't know you
guys know my god but that was like the
crazy thing about us party and was like
psychedelics ecstasy coke weed was like
that weed wasn't even partying like that
was like to the point where like you
smoke weed to go work out you'd smoke
weed to go play frisbee golf or you'd
smoke weed go to class yeah like and so
yeah it was oh you still do a nice tasty
line here and there no I got offered it
this weekend yeah because we are you
afraid your heart will stop her hey
steel yeah that's what I worry about a
colic tasty life yeah I'm really done it
you never like it's phenomenal I like
down is not like a lab no yeah hang
myself from snow bro yeah
not if very few people there like this
mad Devils dancing by I would be I would
even suggest that you would do all the
cocaine what is this area where once you
started though
you even added you because you're a
positive guy and you just be excited
you'd be like this is [ __ ] great it's
like it's like this like my buddy did
blow and he and he took a shower at my
apartment he comes out he goes bro
that's the best shower I've ever [ __ ]
that I don't know what kind of shower
that is you got a next but that's a few
hundred hours so that's a lot of
positives there's a lot of positives
look great does the other good the great
saying of cocaine is like like when you
it's very common for two dudes do do
cocaine and start a business together
oh right you like dude let's [ __ ]
start a video business check it out even
though they're obsolete if we had video
but we go plate think about this we go
plate and we put a prestigious all of a
sudden you know the dude the cauliflower
hot press these gold plated video
[ __ ] tapes you're you you were a coke
guy though bruh
no no I just did it a few times I did it
Hardy it was you know can I tell you
even this weekend uh we found it rude to
turn down coke like if someone offer you
coke expensive in LA and no growing up
like in Florida if someone had coke and
I offered you coke that's like going
them going hey man like gonna be distant
I wanted to do a line you're like I'll
do a line I'm bear [ __ ] to do so I'll do
like a bump or something yeah bump
because like a bum turns into [ __ ]
all the cocaine I used to be really good
I'd do just a couple bumps and be set
for the night placing darts like in
really all those Dargis of coke is I
mean meaning we starts without come we
had one crazy night it was like right
after I start in New York I come back to
Orlando my buddies almost say their
names but I'll just oh they may I'll
just say their first names John Brent
and another guy we're all one of them's
got a kid I shouldn't I shouldn't Olin
Mike Jason and and Derek okay
they want to guys yeah good guys one of
them got a kid we all hang out and I
can't we go back to my place and do coke
but listen my I just have this brand new
baby and my wife is not like she does
not know this
me so if we do yeah yeah let's just lock
it down and and we'll look okay what I
could keep the cocaine away from the
baby he's got a dick load and so we're
like Oh deep put on some Steely Dan put
on some some Frank black something we
can really read into we bout to go
Scarface yeah and it's like it's like
2:00 in the morning like there's a great
way to end the night well you know what
we'll do this until sunrise or like a
night yeah start doing it there's an
ocular door all of a sudden it's our guy
buddy Jason no whatever honey but it
doesn't look like Jason he it's in an
orchid outfit and he's got an organ
truck out front and he's like hey I
understand you guys got a little blow or
like yeah and he's like ah come on
here's the deal I don't have any money
on me now
but if you can give me a few lines and
maybe a little to take with me I'll just
spray your house with the college's of
this guy we're like a whole sad like hey
the whole the stories and just do coke
with us like your mom we're bucking up
our high man man like Jesus you got a
spray I'll take you roaches give me a
couple bumps man yeah how pic yeah can
we bring him in and after a few bumps
spraying a house lens I was a bad idea
we're like you got more equipment in
there like I do so we all pack up we all
get working things were spraying his
house all of a sudden the wife comes out
good what a baby she's like because one
of them's like you got silverfish and
she's like what the [ __ ] and we look
like we are [ __ ] stormtroopers
sitting there without a Johanna
oh my god silverfish me like spraying
toxic chemicals oh [ __ ] there's like
those nights I feel like I missed them
like I miss them they were fun but I
couldn't do them now because by my
biggest problem was the next day the
next day I was a I was a real legit mess
I was a depressed ER well the dopamine
crash or what like hardcore like to the
point where like I haven't done it I
haven't done it probably and since I was
like probably 27 28 I did it on accident
last time I did it I did it on accident
one of my buddies had a bullet where you
flip it and then you turn it and you
just hit it and they couldn't figure it
out I was like you guys are [ __ ]
idiots let me show you and I did it I
went I want you take it you load it pack
it in flip it them anyone oh [ __ ] I just
did code and I had a go on stage of the
Boston company Cup that night and I was
like oh my god what do I do
and my other buddies like do the other
nostril you can't leave it on even like
annoying helpful yeah so we hit and I
load it hit it and man I was magic on
stage I bet yeah magic yeah and I was
like I mean [ __ ] do that
yeah that's the best idea ever our boss
wedding yeah yeah it was it was popping
comic I was in New York you have it that
no for West Third Street not exist me my
dad yeah we caught the bomb you're
having to come in here so we're in and
then the next day I was laying I would
lived on right across street from the
cellar and I'd had Chinese food and
someone said is there MSG in this
Chinese food and I was like oh my god
I'm gonna and I thought I was having a
heart attack I thought I was dying and I
was like I was like this isn't I was
like this is that was a mistake last
night and that's the last time I'll do
it I haven't done it since yeah yeah it
just it was a lot of fun but then next
day man I'm not that guy I can't have
you ever smoked or eating a hash brownie
or had you read too much THC we've been
like we that's the worst yeah yeah it's
the worst brother were sued I had to
have already lying talked me down I
caught him I was like we're just a
brownie edibles audibles are though I
hate a brownie
I call them up in the middle of the
night I go dude I think I'm dying is
you're not gonna die I can't I can't
feel myself breathing or I can't hear my
heart you guys are did you know that LA
Speedwagon guy shot up to speed weed
dudes great but he's like yeah I was
give me extra stuff you know so he's
weed to sleep at night and he gave me
this chocolate bar I get easy with
stuffing super powerful I like what like
[ __ ] half of a square I was like oh
my god I like edibles it gives me anger
the next thing I kind of groggy yeah my
girls moms 1/2 1/2 a bar got you really
hot no.9 half the quarter of a bar a
quarter of that behind a little square
of the sink it's a big bar check this
out my ID go out of town we're doing
work some like that my girl's mom stays
with us she's having anxiety can't sleep
my girl goes brand new weed god you
shouldn't she goes wild like your soleus
know he has chocolate you just need to
stock with she gives her half of the
whole bar now dude no it was like a
funky top it elephant tranquilizer come
on
she was like foaming at the mouth her
flushing look if elephant tranquilizer
dad came over was like what a mouth
but did you give my wife can you die
that way you can't doubt I know but I
definitely have definitely thought I was
going to definitely cannot OD on
marijuana okay there's you can you
there's no one's ever done it so so so
so the new high for seven months
Jesus she was so sick my manager calling
you taking you fix this reg sorry I
[ __ ] up okay so they're there right
now are you able to get that home
anytime this afternoon yeah I can be
there this afternoon all right I'm in
Venice so it's gonna be a while six are
you leaving now he's going to be there
what how long do we gonna go on this by
another hour I'm gonna go another hour
so I can be there an hour 30 minutes
probably - considering traffic yeah yeah
yeah yeah just fix it because this is a
really this podcast is really good like
I listen to podcast seven o'clock is a
glamour and jamming reminder okay great
great great all right I gotta go I love
you bye um yeah I I took marijuana and
I've been talking about this on stage
trying to figure it out so I don't want
to sound hacky because I know there's
guys that have done it but I've had
times where your brain starts having
independent conversations with itself
and he's like oh you're so high he's a
gay man dude I have a question do I
remind you to breathe and you're like oh
[ __ ] me and then and then I don't have
mind you hit it and then you're like
wait I'm not breathing and he's I will
we haven't been breathing in a while
like and then you start going that's the
worse when you start going you know your
heart's racing and I've had that a
number of times and and that's why I
don't really eat marijuana I'll smoke it
but I smoke it in really small I would
do vapor it's very real small yeah yeah
edibles I don't edibles a Trouble Man
like Joey were those Death Star's dude
it what's wrong with you man Joey's
flipped my dad marijuana be heard this
story yes you tried yeah Joey comes to
Easter one year and he's got [ __ ]
edible popcorn and he goes oh mr. Kay
wanna see the devil's dip tonight and my
dad's like what's that Joey is so
aggressive Jim yeah yeah look at Easter
and he's devil gonna dick now no and my
dad just takes a handful of popcorn did
he know what it was I had no idea
there's a picture I don't know where you
can find it if you could look online
it's on my facebook my personal one
there's a picture of Joey giving the
popcorn of my dad it's for pictures like
that eating it they're all connected
like like like you're in a meth my
sister's going what the
[ __ ] and then me laughing hysterically
and then I was forced to eat marijuana
with my dad so my dad's like buddy what
do I do and I was like you I'll go in
with you and so I ate it and I don't
like eating marijuana but we had the
greatest [ __ ] night of our realize it
didn't get where we're sitting out it's
like by seven o'clock it's we're still
very high having a cigar having a
whiskey and I say to my dad I said my
dad why don't you like me because I'm
high I'm comfortable and he goes uh I
don't know I was wondering about that
hold on this is greatest hold on all
right ha
I got a different great question Birds
Eye busy a lot of Le mant figure out
it's your [ __ ] face your whole life
is that [ __ ] smirk don't like that
face here the shape your face was was
your dad a season trip reloading smoke
weed alone oh no no no not at all okay
yeah this is great okay so keep going
I'm sorry so I he goes uh but think
about that a lot my dad didn't go to
therapy
now he's high and he's like he's humbled
and he goes uh you remind me of my dad
and I said okay and he lost his dad when
he was 13 and it really [ __ ] him up
really [ __ ] him up forever like stuff
anybody I kill he'll be walking through
Gelson's and see like a something that
his dad used to like to put on his
sandwiches and just start crying and uh
and he goes you remind me of my dad and
I'm afraid to get close to you because I
look at your lifestyle I think you're
just gonna die and I said okay I go I'm
not gonna die hold on you at this time I
am probably right around for you 42 okay
not young and so I go how can we fix
this he goes I don't know I said well
like what honest guy though what an
honest guy not thankfully we nice to the
dinner whenever steady 42 years go by
yeah 50 highest [ __ ] yeah don't you like
me I've been thinking about that man
yeah he's like obviously I love you I
just you make me uncomfortable where
relation their father yes
unaware of it unaware of it until my
parents got divorced I need 22 to 21
kind of older yeah and uh unaware of it
that we didn't have like like just he
just didn't know how to like sometimes
you call him and say I love you and I'll
go okay you know honey that's just Jenna
yeah this is generation and so then I
say to my dad I go I go think how can we
fix this and he goes I just I want I
need I need you to do a lot of things
you're not willing to do I said like
what he goes I need you to get a
cardiologist I need to get he starts
listing off all these things then he's
eating you're not gonna die
he wants to prove that I'm not gonna die
I go listen I don't care I go if you
wanna you be in charge that knee goes he
literally lit up he's like I can get you
a cardiologist I go you do all of it get
get your cardiology or your medical guys
you get them online you pick them for me
and I'll go and will and that and he's
like he's like you do that for me I was
like yeah I love you like I don't want I
want you to like me like I want you to
be able to have dinner with my family
and not be over judged judging me
everything I do because if I would go to
eat something more he'd lose his mind if
I had another drink he'd lose his mind
and he would be very passive-aggressive
his dad passed away from what stroke and
it's and his debt he's like my dad was
the life of the party you seem to be the
life of the party those are the guys
that die fast I just my dad's never
liked that a deep emotion for him man
yeah that I mean I I got chance at your
last night in command his dad died of
like 40 yeah and have you had a
cardiology and that was the vision Rydia
biggest problem is I went to the
cardiologist he goes you're perfect I
did a CT scan he goes zero blockage and
I started eating like a [ __ ] pig and
that's how I got to be 265 pounds is
that I'd literally because they gave me
the kid gave me the green light put me
on all the medicine and I was like so I
can't died from this as I was I was
judging it I was eating healthier
because of I didn't know if I was
healthy or not once I said I was fine I
was like I can party now since doing
that are you near dad closer now is it
all good it's kind of it's gotten it's
kind of a lot better it's kind of a lot
better recall the other day like very
like he was like I'm just so proud of
you I just I can't even tell you such a
good son oh there was the other thing he
thinks I piss away money so I had my
financial manager and my and my business
manager my financial planner my business
manager send all the documents to him
and he like you know like hey Bert's
gonna be fine yeah like what is your dad
did lawyer
what kind he real estate really is a
lawyer but he changed the flow of what
lawyers were doing in the real estate
business in Florida and but
and so it was very successful but not
until after I graduated college
he stays in shape no no my dad's the
kind of guy like I've said this before
but he got hooked on speed without
knowing it was speed because he had a
doctor going if you take this it's
whatever the pro hit from whatever the
pro phen-fen was whatever friend on more
appetite stop jab tight and I remember
one Easter I came back I was buzzed and
it was early in the morning I came home
and I was like I'm tired I don't know if
I'm gonna make this party the girls were
little so Easter was a really big deal
my dad's like buddy take one of my pills
you'll really wake up and I was like
okay and I took one I was like dad
reading speed I was like I was like at
let's over talk to everyone now at the
party you take an easy lesson I take two
a day I'm like that's amazing the focus
I have I could just sit there and work
all day long I go do you get panic at 90
goes yeah yeah you panic at night I'm
like yeah you take a [ __ ] at speed I go
give up on yourself folding laundry goes
all the time kiss-up own [ __ ] laundry
organizing my Glock garage I go yes
you're a [ __ ] build speed head yeah
and then an addict yeah and write this
so interesting man like you like so many
people are doing at least one drug in
this country at least I mean think about
it
right whether it's prozac some kind of a
potential you just have to try to the
drug is asked from the drugs i reprogram
those are some very well girls I'm
talking about sort of mind-altering
drugs so whether it's an suppressants
reuptake inhibitors you know whatever
the xanax annex or or or Russian society
or then there's wee-wee is also
considered like you know you're a type
of mind-altering drug I mean but I mean
if you think about how many people are
actually doing at least something a
pills pills that's that's a [ __ ] there I
did a backyard slingshot in in Utah two
telephone poles on her feet in the air
bungees over them they pulled them down
harness you in put you on the back of an
ATV
and it takes off and when you can't hold
on anymore you shoot 80 miles per hour
into a canyon back and forth and so I'm
about to do it the guy says to me how
much do you weigh
I go to 25 at the time and he goes a
little that could be sketchy I was like
what he's like he may hit the ground
worst-case scenario you break your back
oh my go oh so one of the more
mom's that was a Mormon compound she
said can I get you anything and I was
like I would love a cocktail she's I get
where Mormon we don't really do that and
then she comes out with cooking sherry I
was like I'm not that bad
yeah okay laughs but then we get done
and one of the dad says to me dude eyes
you should have just taken a xanax I
don't have any xanax and he goes oh we
take of my candy out here all came
because it's not to the church and
overlooked xanax and and and mood Bill
crack [ __ ] by the way if you're Mormon
and you're upset of what I'm saying is
its inaccurate then I'm wrong but that's
what their experience with these my
experience was they were taking but they
were cool with taking pills no weed no
asset no go there anyway they won't you
have sex with let you do anal yeah okay
you know I'm saying those Mormons man
that's true though that's true all right
you got so the ones I know again not
every Mormons down for the backdoor
action
yeah ones I knew in Boulder Colorado
yeah it would be like no I don't have
sex you [ __ ] me nationally it could put
me on it I feel like that's so much
darker I all right I mean I guess I'd
rather do that well they say there's
common knowledge that in a lot of
cultures where virginity is very much
esteemed there was a girl drawl a girl
like listen you ma'am i i I've noticed
more I've met your offense is that mass
plain natural you can bang my ass and
not not like I'm saving my cooter for
for my husband's welcome please use done
that's the famous alcohol the [ __ ]
pills all right I pick your poison
right now sold in the ass but yeah even
even indigenous cultures like even like
a drought history they've always looked
for things that were mind-altering
whether it was I think human means have
as me to kind of experiment with their
brains like I guess when it works like
you remember the first time you had
coffee and you were like I feel like a
million [ __ ] box I was working at a
law firm and I walked six miles home I
was like [ __ ] it I'm gonna walk home
yeah finally I was like I feel [ __ ]
amazing
can you imagine you get that feeling
again I think so much coffee it it does
not half man but it definitely does a
little now but you know I'll have
serious withdrawals on half coffee yeah
crazy drug withdrawals yeah I I wish at
that time I was I just worked at a law
firm and I was
my dad got me a job my only thing that
they didn't need me but they knew my dad
and they respected my dad and so they're
like one guy goes just make coffee I was
like when he was just every time I come
into the pop it would be full
okay how about that and so I was like
okay guy had a breathing apparatus and
he used to come in on his [ __ ] thing
goes they're [ __ ] it better be fresh
those are good fresh and then one time I
said to someone I go what do I do with
these half-full pots of coffee and the
girl goes I think he's just drink them
and I was like okay so I would line up
six cups of coffee to make sure there's
always a full copy I'm [ __ ] shaking
the first day I'm shaking I'm like
[ __ ] amazing like I'm having
conversations with everyone and then but
I've had too much coffee where you get
sick me too yeah I I would say I'd do
that probably once every two weeks
yeah from real busy I'm getting is not
expect oh yeah every give it two weeks
come up like oh god I've had too much
like maybe you're trying too long I just
I love coffee I like love the fatigue I
love having a iced tea I've drinks like
one thing about me and my brother we
always meet like I was me drink so you
know so I always have a drink my
father's always drinks always drinks and
then if I it's a busy day like I need a
copy of coffee then some you out get a
coffee and I'm doing these big coffee
and I'm like hold I got like I like 14
shots of expresso in a day like I don't
feel good I don't feel good at all for
it in a head hot a lot yeah yeah I can't
I can't I we straight
I used a grip fuel remember that lets us
dangerous do they sit eight nine a day
god damn with a cup of coffee wait three
mister dude design a day my 30 nano York
yeah email confident its yeah it said it
said on the back take three in the
morning 3:00 at the afternoon three at
night and then my head I'm like so we're
green lip for nine so Kareem Lee so I
would and I worked at Barnes & Noble and
I'd pop nine and have a coffee you need
energy about no [ __ ] I didn't be
raging a Barnes and Noble what would
that do to you oh you're [ __ ] Tweaker
sorry I've told this story before but
I'll talk very quickly I you just start
thinking crazy but then you're like feel
good like I need to [ __ ] work out so
I'd go down to the basement
take the freight elevator
down go down so no one could walk into
me and I [ __ ] workout like a lunatic
get my underwear push-ups [ __ ] squat
forearm raises with the Bible I'm not
just [ __ ] with the fire and I'm just
every day I'm like I'm like I'm getting
paid I'm eatin healthy I was eating tuna
with a can of fresh vegetables that's
what I'd have and I was like I'm losing
weight this is what I this is my thing
I'll read books I'll get smart I'll get
in shape this is what Hollywood's
looking for hey legit and then my boss
was like after like a week two weeks
doing that he's like hey man you know we
have cameras up you quicker and so they
had been watching me work out in the
basement in my underwear and then come
back to work and they're like this guy's
a [ __ ] lunatic toys off you in your
underwear I'm working as it was in the
Astor Place Barnes & Noble didn't have
air conditioning and so I would come up
the first couple times on one come on so
kid cuz you come up you be like holy
[ __ ]
and so I was like I got a so now I'm
having times where I'm drying off like
walking in circles drying off and so
yeah I was uh that was that rip fuel and
I got to be honestly I just really kind
of addicted to it because I it really
hard coming off of that because you like
so what I was just [ __ ] sit here and
do nothing all day yeah it was your
adrenal glands
- they're so saturated we think that
they it never comes back you see I think
like a 14 or 16 year old kid died from
too much caffeine you think like a
mountain Dew energy drinks like four
cups coffee and diet yeah yeah Ivan had
an MIT just a weak heart though what can
I say stock that up as the major yeah
I'm an energy drink in eight years dude
I mean either I go I don't [ __ ] him the
such garbage and then we were in a coma
and the coffee was sorry Oklahoma but
the cafe and the green room was so bad
on the calf I was gone staged copy it's
kind of like my sage going oh [ __ ] man
there's no coffee like I need energy and
then I look at brown like a night game
when I was Red Bulls I've had one
forever and those what's gonna do
I just goes living like that's not very
smart show went great but then we get
done I'm laying him down like like I can
only sleep March 1
I just do the night wise white [ __ ]
games but you don't really you know I
didn't say well oh oh god bet about the
6:00 a.m.
home brothers are ready acting anyone
Williams back what's up not much man
before I have that late night lonely
texting [ __ ] management section yeah how
about that dinner y'all hey man it's
what about my I don't know what are you
doing I'm next door Mike I know what he
right here now [ __ ] did that that's
what you know there's one of us doesn't
having to do we'll just be like like
will we like we'll do a whole podcast
yeah then we'll go eat now we've been
together for four [ __ ] hours right
yeah I got to go home
he'll some night he'll be like on I
induce he'll be like what are you doing
I go not much man I gotta go you guys
yeah you follow me to my car goes dude
you'll sit in my car and I'm not getting
him out holy he's too big yeah I wish I
may go to hack him oh man and I'm like
dude I can't get this fun there's not
I'm not gonna get him out of my car I
got to hang out with me that I'll hang
out I go I really have to go he's mad
hang a little while longer
so I'm so glad to know that people have
that late night where you can't sleep on
your like and you go in like you're
going I got friends in London right when
they got to be away from the devil then
eight nine yeah yep again I'm going out
just in an email that scary guy thing
that up didn't get back to me okay I'll
just like do a few things just searching
for anyone to respond back hey what's
that what a stock market in Tokyo doing
right now
DMing just random fans hey just solve
this how's your night going what the
[ __ ] man dude are you pissed so bad we
all have this some ESCO pissed all right
just some current events with the
machine up in here
who keeps put around a bath with the
machine I by the way have a right of a
meeting with my two writers for my TV
show tonight it's that bit
thanks just yeah why yeah I don't look
at things so I don't I never think to go
I'm kind of bad - yeah your met your you
don't have a manager help me honor I do
but it's just like like I wouldn't I
would never make you go through my
manager yeah
yeah and so you're like yellows do too I
go yeah I got this how I am and my head
I was like nice I get to work out who
get an assist and I'm like I'm just too
expensive
all right God all right first kind of
event the TJ Dillashaw Cody garbage
fight is absolutely one percent off now
so could you over there our yeah yes
back so you LM Errol and Robert
Whittaker will be fighting combing
events and for the interim title
hilarious in their plays it look at your
Romero's body for a second Gunners
reticulate like like it's so I love that
fight for Robert Whittaker really yep I
think beat so really I think knocked him
out porque cuz his hands yeah I just
think he's younger I've never you know I
think though the OL Romero widening
fight you know Weidman's off see you
know not the same guy he is he's still
phenomenal fighter and he was doing well
not fight I just I don't know like
looking at fighting stands a quicker I
think he hits harder his anti
wrestling's [ __ ] good the older male
doesn't use wrestling that much you know
he's more of a structure these days he's
athletic
I mean when it guys better striking I
just feel like it's whit at this time
man
I think you all beat a jock ray but that
the main event
Maina Nunez yeah chef chef Schenker
against Nunez [ __ ] Shevchenko beats
or brilliance I thought I thought that
the last I going fought three Shevchenko
came on as of late 2005 render she would
have beat her
she's like a 17 time world championships
and over some ice right yeah I think the
noonas is a sad sight I thought I picked
the 200 Uggs
I would assume we'll see that's gonna be
really good
what else you got you alright the next
one is Live Nation they're the ones that
do all the concerts
they're going to offer refunds for all
the concerts that are going on in
England that are coming up which are
well cuz know Katy Perry I mean kiss
waka flocka hold on their block yet
they're cancelling all of all yeah
because of evening another they think
that another attack is imminent and it
has been planned on
I level so you know I guess this is what
I heard on the BBC and I don't know but
a lot of these guys that were trained in
Syria in the in you know in the war and
understand have a knowledge of
explosives and stuff I guess some of
them are in in Europe and that's the
worry oh my god so what was the thing
this guy this guy's family were refugees
from Libya yeah yeah and then under the
Gustav right now Qaddafi Qaddafi regime
so they fled England Manchester he's one
of four something like that and then
some where he went
obviously [ __ ] batshit crazy well
that's why I wish they'd also tell me
what what how much Katy Perry gets of
the door oh I would love to know that
would they make all mushy they make
crazy money touring and then also
working nice merges yeah Bieber maybe
I'm trying to know somebody at merch it
would be crazy about because I like
those big bands I like I wonder what
Phil Collins gets for a show and I like
to think about that I think about that
all the time so I sort of hurt my
brother evils had made I think like I
was talking to one of their their
manager because he was on set when of
this long time about MADtv but this is
way past when the Eagles were the Eagles
and they had made that year already he
told me they'd made a hundred million
dollars that's the kind of money we're
talking by the way I can tell you but
one of my favorite things with Segura as
we talk about how much we get in
theaters and it's optional I love that's
within yield your biggest asset here man
someone election those numbers like
being me and like I gotta check
yesterday Senate patron I said delete
Dalia we talked [ __ ] back and forth you
know just really like oh thanks life or
you know just messing around and then
hope someone sent a check to Lee or
someone you're when we talked about you
just like oh my gates if you celebrate
different look like much for you man
yeah I like that's so [ __ ] close I'm
some money I was in Nashville's or he's
just got back from China or from Asia so
he's not he's not all he's not he's
really not celebrating the entertainment
business at all he just wants to be back
and we're doing a festival so he's like
by it and I'd done a one-nighter the
night before in Alabama and I had my
check and it was it was a big for
one-nighter and it and you could do the
math but it was big for a one-nighter
and i just dropped it in all his lap and
i go this is what you've been missing
out on buddy does all this is
interesting and just rips it on ah all
right by the way it could give a [ __ ]
about money he could give pieces I think
you know I don't think I met mainly well
I don't know why is that well at all
really not a factor one's done anything
you like me no no I don't know that all
such a good he needs $35,000 a year to
live that's right that's what II mean oh
by the way lent Bobby Lee I think
$40,000 lent it to no I we just we hang
on the same Krueger we've never actually
I don't think met he is the best he's a
brute to a fault brutally honest like I
like that yeah well yeah you can rub you
the wrong way we doing then you know the
Pens how well friends you are yeah yeah
he'll say stuff to me were like the only
person I've ever met that that like
almost artistically brutally honest no
no no Rogen's got Rogen will will skirt
issues if it's important I'll be really
honest with ya but uh is Daniel Tosh
Tosh will say things to you were you
encountered you off-guard you're like
you know I didn't him do that to very
famous people yes where he goes oh no I
can never have lunch with you
III don't like what like like as it nice
yeah well we'll just we should talk
because no I talked to you about for
about four minutes three years ago that
was entirely too long yeah swear to God
in front of it this is to a famous
person we still do a lot of standing I
was like yeah because what a storm and
then I see him he just saw me other day
at least he's about he's I love am i I
yeah I love Daniel butcher and I are
planning a surprise party for him at his
house oh cool
so we're gonna get everyone you guys are
more than welcome to come I'm like we're
all just gonna get a party bus and they
show up at his house when it's done
renovated on a Sunday early knock on the
door and go surprise and then just
bubble ring is ready let's get whether
he had a ready area on your film it and
we're going to
film it and then we'll give it a toss
point others so they can err they're
pretty close to Dan no no no no hear how
he knows about it we talked about it
it's coming it's a [ __ ] storm Unitas
got without it see listen no you don't
know when the barge is gonna you don't
know when the barge is going to shore up
oh yeah but it's out there all right and
when it does come you look so free will
you know I made know I've known him for
13 years and I but I don't talk to him
I'll call him on the phone or anything I
told he's the guy I had like when I saw
him you know what got him to the dance
the stand-up that got him to the dance
I haven't seen him you know in a while
but to me like that [ __ ] was so good I
just don't stand it for a long time and
I do just fine and I was like well
that's the funny should I've ever seen
you know music it was that good he's you
I I really I respect his comedy beyond
but I he's a very sweet guy I don't know
if everyone gets that from him but
that's what I get so I always have I can
always shorthand with him very quickly
and I really like him but everyone that
I know that knows him well is like he
was not going to be happy about this I
was like yeah I know that's what's gonna
make it brilliant is me and Bill Byrne
Rogen with all our families waiting
outside going you think he's gonna open
the door
oh my god be so awfully where I can pull
you into it dude enough so every other
high like you guys got you who sits in
their living rooms now no that's gonna
be hilarious kidding it's the door you
seem done ain't ya amen
and I ain't coming in and then call him
hey man he's got that great house in
point dune or something right he's got a
guy he's just renovating it is what
someone said to me one of his confidence
like I wouldn't do it right now he's
renovating that's why he's on tour so
wait until it's done and I went nothing
what we're gonna do
yeah I'm gonna [ __ ] that place out what
else yeah Jim all right the next one
rides on that a little bit so during the
attacks there's two homeless
two homeless men that helped some of the
people that were hurt by the damage
they're like kids with nails and they're
you know everywhere on their bodies so
these two homeless people and towards
the that people that were injured and
helped them out so they're getting a lot
of attention
on social media and other [ __ ] these
[ __ ] who are targeting children
you yes a positive story but this is a
positive story I don't care so two of
these guys they've been already given
like just through social media people
made these like GoFundMe pages and
everything else to give them upwards of
forty to fifty thousand dollars each and
then someone from West Ham do you know
the soccer team boy I am co-owner is
offering to give them like free rent for
six months or something like that to get
them back on their feet
okay he might be a drug addict I had
that seasonal blow through that way and
the exact never ends well by the way
that's the first thing I thought it was
I I literally it was like are you gonna
die I go LD you get that guy forty fifty
thousand dollars I have a feeling that
he might have something he may it might
be mental illness which is one thing but
it could also be that you know well not
only doesn't you that draw crooked like
that it's there's something going on
yeah that looks like you that might give
it away exactly rhythm is a tweaking
yeah I got some ideas about the
government but like you know that the
thing that sucks is is uh is you know
ultimately he's gonna go like I told you
this would work out you know I mean for
forty grand is not is not a lot of times
what a guy like that it needs right so
so my so we we said so job would be cool
me Berto he looks like he's going to
come up with conspiracy theories do well
[ __ ] G Gillian lines of blow and
probably done something's going on yeah
my so there's a guy who used to sell
sodas he was a essentially a homeless
guy but he would sell he'd have a big
damn Central Park everybody playing
softball and he was a great guy
sweetheart of a guy and he would walk
around and he had sodas and beers in a
big sort of plastic bag with ice yeah
and you bought in summertime you buy and
he was great let's just say his name is
Chuck and Chuck was just always a
fixture and a great guy hey man how's
your day that good good I am yeah what
is it we're like man he's a good guy man
you want good things to happen for that
guy he'd show up with that [ __ ] bag
and he'd be thirsty and always have beer
always have soda and sometimes they have
ice cream and he's just great and he had
energy and he was a skinny guy and he
was just poor and like what the [ __ ] is
going on with him
he so you get again a guy who is always
there a fixture and you wanted good
things for him well Chuck won lottery Oh
Chuck won lottery logic one lottery
lottery Chuck one's a little bit lottery
no Chuck won the lottery about a couple
hundred a couple hundred hundred
thousand two hundred thousand dollars
[ __ ] and uh Chuck he should have been
cut this beard and then Chuck showed up
about stop three weeks later uh
literally literally almost naked and
just so dirty and just just [ __ ] and
he's regular they're gonna wear no
drinks in the okay here here yeah he has
been shooting some hearing his name I
know a lot of us straight to the alien
country been on my and Chuck a lot of
sunny yeah that was the end of that in
fact they never really saw him again
that was the lottery with Sassenach ago
he was he would do happen yeah what was
keeping him sober was the fact that he
needed money just to eat what what he
didn't need was two hundred thousand
dollars a windfall of cash well yeah so
he can go [ __ ] crazy which is what he
did you mean he did investments for one
cage well he ended up dead I think I
would be really good if I won the
lottery
yeah yep yep I probably no one would
ever see me again so so how much money
would you need to never be seen again
though every time I lost you money he's
not my [ __ ] you know is that 20 mil oh
yeah yeah yeah what I need now 20 mil
will be good if you can't exactly be
gave me one of those a hundred and
ninety million dollar lotteries okay I'm
going to an island to buy in an island
I'm probably gonna get a divorce my wife
doesn't wanna live in Long Island he is
so bored on that island Burt nope not me
I disagree I'm gonna party without a
jack and Danielle's a nice guy fly
people in that's not bad I would tear
through that cash that's that's one of
my what would you do
oh I don't about in st. Vincent I think
I buy this bar called foxy the guy who
owns virgin yeah I bought no I buy I
move onto an island I'd buy big course
and start buying up real estate but I
don't a beach bar and call it Burt's
beach bar and I
I'd have guitars i define flying like
Eddie Vetter I playing big musicians Pam
through the nose Ron I just have like my
friends down and people that can come in
and afford to buy my hundred dollar
drinks if I sell it's going to be hey
bro you guys a hot dog
I learned all the money weed out the
riffraff it's like it's the old serial
violence you had to have you have only
the rich I know I'm just the people
though if you guys came down as free
drinks right but never stranger and you
want to hang out I'm done you got your
watching Eddie Vedder he's playing
acoustic on a ukulele yeah it's not oh
yeah I got a Ford Eddie Vetter I'm not
going to go broke after after three
months seeing a little old I like this
story I do die thought about this a lot
now what about girls you'd have a lot of
a lot of my wife's doesn't my wife or
has already said that that's not her
plan so I'd be like cool horse I'm going
to set you up in the mountains here's an
email you're not divorced we're gonna
say together it's going to be a very
open at this point they don't really
share very hard to talk yeah with 2030
million I was very difficult to get tell
me that we need to say to get what 190
now so 40 million I'll bump you were the
way she talks to me yeah I can talk to
me like that way I wind up not going
open a line when you got over 200
million dollars in the bank now so so
now you're you're hanging your you got
your friends you got berths bar I love
Bert's bar that's not fantastic cool are
you flying in Russian girls what what's
going on I'm just curious
probably you know girls melting pot I
thought it would definitely be a melting
pot it would be I wouldn't do the
Internet girls like the the Instagram
stars and stuff you just maybe found
America and Eastern or was it in fact
I'd famous I probably a lot of like just
like chicken always want to have a sex
with in college like a lot of girls like
other kind of married now they'll break
that's not fun
well you'd be shocked I don't think
they're also 50 if I said hey yeah I got
a bunch of your friends come down to the
island see what happens
yeah dig it then they see a girl from
your college dome they show up like I'm
on mom now I know that's what I'm into I
like that older is law a rental car
that's got some roses okay I guess I'm
with you on that I do know that was
violent that was one scenario I had the
other scenario is I just do I just set
up comedy touring the way I want to do
it what wait first bar do you have
Brendan in like a cage and it's like if
you grow I want to get pregnant this guy
going out you know what I mean do you
want a baby looks like him he's like a
weird [ __ ] like you understand this bar
is going to be next level okay so so uh
so so I hit up
John John Jones right okay and I say
dude I got a proposition for you okay
I'm putting a $250,000 on your back and
a backpack
I'm going to send in six guys they can
get it off your backpack they keep the
money but if you keep the money I'm
tripling it for you
you know what this sounds like they
adverts dr. Monroe's Island yeah and
then put Mabel our [ __ ] I love that I'm
and then I bring up bringing a real cage
I bring in everyone and then I got and
then John Jones awright and then other
fighters come in the Diaz brothers are
in there they're getting high everyone's
having a good time and then they're
watching all this and then I was like
dude it was the most amazing time of my
life and all I just had like two drinks
for 200 bucks he's [ __ ] the trainee I
said then all my friends are like dude
Burt is like a philanthropist like he's
well he flew in on a private jet is that
you I'm Muscat party I'm just saying
yeah you're we saw the Diaz brothers
fight baboon baboon and then through
this money see his brothers baboons yet
both you all of those one baboon they
beat the [ __ ] that badly I felt that
their drunken climbing high off his ass
full of coke the whole [ __ ] knapsack
full of cash yeah and then six guys were
dead behind them man was it really all I
[ __ ] all the no one weird older like
girls from Florida State with kids it
was a real [ __ ] show I mean I spent two
grand on like four dreams man it was a
nightmare people are right now he was
it's a tight knit there's none the
baboon freaked the [ __ ] out so you're
throwing [ __ ] everywhere and then his
friends King berkians got huh guys 100
grand and kill a baboon and dude and
then but the Cameron ain't gave her one
era and shot that [ __ ] right through
the heart no one could say anything to
me they're like no seriously I saw
cheetah fight' a wolf and they're like
birds having cage fights with animals
are like no Wilkins and his eyelid his
eyelids are lucky why jab the Japanese
have bug fights we seen that [ __ ] no oh
I think I have I think I definitely have
yeah they do like the wasp yeah but that
was everywhere yo beat everybody
that's [ __ ] beetle that's [ __ ] to
be visited exterior
yeah you can't get it if you if you want
to lose money an island do that
it's that Popeye yeah yeah we even tell
her more people can see it you a big
killer
I got even talking about everyone right
on hey you're seeing the Beatles like
that in real life when I just run even
bring it up run it down am sure it was a
$25,000 buy-in to see if I could knock
this guy out and no one did it he was up
all night guys's our steel chin just up
all guys I would do it if you gave me a
show where I could do whatever the [ __ ]
I wanted what any idea that came to my
mind like I sometimes I would get those
pitch them to the scripts people I'd be
like like one time we were all drinking
and I was like I think I could build a
pool and they're like oh my god that I
could like I bet I could google it and
nightmare hold up on YouTube and just
build a pool I bet I could do that no
like you definitely could until the pool
and I was like I was like give me a show
give me a budget I'll build my [ __ ]
pool see I like the idea Burt does this
burn things you can do this I literally
there are times where I go I could like
I could definitely do that I could build
a roller coaster in my backyard
yeah I trust it yeah trust you again
you're in degree I'm not just really
drunk
it's the Builder - have you seen that I
forget where they're at that some huge
concert I know when they line up all the
porta-potties and people run on top of
them yeah some guys like I can clear
that
and he's hammered in college any stones
buddies like I can easy I'm in track in
high school I can run over the top that
and jump over and clear that like let's
see things all watch this it's all group
Coosh
yeah Wow like knocked out I'd love to
see her try [ __ ] - except you didn't
show me you know the worst one to pitch
these ideas to is Rogan like that's
stupid why would you do that yeah why
the [ __ ] would you why would you want to
do that I told her one time I think I
was drinking and I go I think me and Tom
Segura could be Cameron Hayes in a race
sorry what but I was like tag-team like
you know we run a marathon and I'll run
a mile Tommy mile yeah we got it we have
any study to go yet he's like really
like no you can't do that you definitely
can't do that he's a monster he's a
beast
hey done what happen you need to be
realistic in these ideas they get hurt I
entertain me for a second there he's shy
yes the right to talk no no not gonna
happen
I was joking around we were with the
Glover Teixeira and I took a picture
with him and then could you'd like to
hang over whatever the [ __ ] it was a lot
it's really cool and I he's talking and
I go now you think I could take him
joking around go could I could easily
and joke without you guys no no stop
stop I'm like I was going to me I'm
calling when I'm with it over there know
that I'm here with everyone I would tell
that's gonna fail no no for 25 years
doesn't matter I'm color is like I was
making a bit I was about to do a bit she
killed I'm like yeah yeah okay Oh could
I was being serious
like I do like is good to have Rogan in
your life because he keeps it real but
like I love when you say like like the
one that stuck in my head I was like I
said it someone I was like I bet I could
become a black belt in jujitsu in five
years and they were like where'd you get
this information once I got hurt on a
podcast that if you're really focused
you could do it in five years and
they're like no no I was Joey was Joey
yeah there's like nobody no you can't is
I've been doing it for years above a
[ __ ] Bluebell I don't even own that
one attendant there a couple guys but I
mean yeah the exception yes exception
did it yeah BJ Penn did I guess honey
Bravo did it in five and a half so
you're saying it also so I well now they
did nice and yeah cuz you have the same
structure as BJ Penn all right it's that
Mickey Mantle gene in my head where I go
I can [ __ ] do that
it's true like we're you go ahead list
we just think big thoughts you're like I
did I could do that yeah my buddy my
buddies I did has never fought but he'll
play baseball but he's like he believes
that he could take anybody like you know
those guys like I mean on a given day if
I were to get at his eyes or a throat
you know there's always that thing to do
that is that is a lot of energy for
those guys yeah I definitely have never
been hit in the face I wanted to
entertain that conversation
what if someone said that other they
could but if anybody was knowing
anything he's going to say well
depending and
it's amazing how that really shows up in
real life though like in real life today
riding our bikes cool and a guy flies by
my daughter and then throws his hands up
in her air at her and I just start going
[ __ ] you buddy
and I [ __ ] pedal up to him because
he's in a car I'm gonna by coming out
her butt in I really took the challenge
I was like I could beat up anybody I
don't know who's in that car I could
beat up anybody yeah I can beat up
anybody right now and I and I and I by
the way I was barefoot and I had a cup
of coffee in my hand and my cell phone
in my middle pocket of mine hoody I was
like I'm not winter Papa Bear mode
though yeah you don't really think of
night and yeah that's what it is what it
is but there's a lot of people to go
look I could beat up anybody in a car
and then you're like no that's bad idea
I should be more like there when I was
young now I'm scared cuz I'm 50 I see a
young dude is getting like cut me off
from a Denali guy a young strong and he
probably trains he's probably like
[ __ ] doing digital time I don't want
to fight that guy
I read their bumper stickers I can tell
about your bumpers oh I can make them
I'm like Gor 297 look John I can tell
you this guy [ __ ] dwarfee - or John Evo
- that it Tom Cruise I've got 31 years
Top Gun is coming back we'll talk then -
now is he gonna be in this he's gonna be
in it and I heard that Val Kilmer was on
ride it and he said he's on board - but
they're not abusing him yeah they're
barely him doing it but you have seemed
off-camera lately
yeah you don't want to see that dad even
before my Canaries in the mine my throat
cancer yeah and Michael Douglas called
him out on it in public you could you
remember that one happen he was given a
speech at somewhere and he was drooling
and he was just kept chopping up his
drool Malcolm by the way no disrespect
to Valerie listening because I think
he's genius yeah he's a bad man he's
like and then Michael Douglas guys comes
out and he goes he has cancer he needs
to be checked and Michael done with had
throat cancer that's right but he said
he got it from his girl right from HPV
yeah and so now Kim was like [ __ ] you I
don't throw cancer I've been tested and
he's like I got throat cancer yeah
really so yeah because he was truly I
was ruled it's a really aggressive like
he's trying to give a speech and his
whole thing's swollen and he's just
I've been really kind of heartbreaking
but the point is no one's putting him in
taught you know I mean if there's a
certain weight limit for a plane you
just can't throw then you ain't thing is
take
sixes and Snickers ass into this [ __ ]
f-16 yeah they're not made for those six
wait what's the plot of the movie I know
the plan I can't say oh you know it for
knowi doesn't read it on my okay I know
yeah I know my Stella isn't it - oh it's
gonna be pretty bad I like miles teller
yeah he's amazing
I like those guys that creep up on you
and you're like oh this dude he's worth
selling it yeah he's about to blow he I
mean he's already killing it please
about to you know get up that upper
echelon of acting yeah yeah he's a
monster
shut up Tom Cruise for crashing thanks
for joining us please this I'm telling
you what I said thanks I mean I'm not
joking around as soon as I got that call
I knew what that was it's a big
production this is more important to me
than that and I'm not [ __ ] around I
love what you guys are doing and I and
I've wanted for a very long time because
I get it all the time on Twitter like
what are you gonna be uptight okay what
are you gonna be on poke it and I always
wanted I'm not that guy that ever goes
hey man can I come on your podcast like
I'm not that dude and when you guys hit
me up I was like so [ __ ] pumped so
you're always welcome man yeah it's not
bad when we're talking in the comic
store and I was like dude when you come
back in the podcast show they're been on
like what [ __ ] yeah you've never divided
yours and then I want it I've always
wanted hit you up a couple of times but
I love that in my pocket I never got it
I didn't get it on I would always reply
when people are like when you get in
Bryan Callen I loved everyone but online
anytime you want I didn't know that I'm
not that guy that I was like I don't ask
for stuff but I love him people have to
be all my podcast so I'm like [ __ ] yeah
oh it just came in a now helps you oh
yeah it makes it like I'll thank God
like I love my dad loves coming like oh
hell yeah we got to go yeah give me a
date come on
this was a blast his sweet tears like
this man cave is a great [ __ ] I just
got a gum taking my [ __ ] to the next
level I came in hammers you out dude
well I got cameras but I got my lighting
package I got I'm gonna get my Carm so
that the audio is better we get a maybe
some air booster some cloud Buster's
tongue you know I Boyd you know we just
we just unplugged your whole setup and
plug it into myself dude if I heard
about the it was
it was all about the monster over here
the best it was announced the Mon yeah
and so uh so I would love to have you
back on I'd love to get you on and and I
appreciate you guys for having me -
thank you brother awesome I'm gonna go
run to this shoot you're a good man have
fun at the shake a guy's a fascist thank
you the best
oh I'm on the road I'm in Hawaii May
31st
San Francisco at Cobbs June 9th and 10th
Sacramento's sold out and then Kansas
City Orlando you can find me everywhere
leaved in a skanks festival I'm on the
road hardcore and then I Instagram and
Twitter to announce all this yeah I just
go to Burt Burt Burt calm with an Ian
you can find all my Instagram on my
Twitter I've increased my Twitter by a
lot of people just by focusing and
putting out videos that can't like that
like putting some attention into them so
yeah check me out there I love it oh
I'll check me out I'm going to be in
June 8th 9th and 10th just added Irvine
improv come see me yellow blood-related
kind of tell you all I just did right
there was figured out the size of your
check and I was like god dammit that's
got to be nice gave me some fun yeah
because you're an 8 9 and 10 come see me
and then I will be in my intro uh
Australia tour Brisbane Sydney's both
sold out in Oakland and Mel born I think
there's less than Tom tickets left in
those all fit hashtag all theaters all
these are all sold out and then June
22nd Gotham comedy club in New York and
July 28th Long Beach Laugh Factory get
everything you need for Brian and myself
keep at kake.com this is a fun kid with
the Machine we're out